[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily the family of
dante wright
speaking out after the 20 year old was
shot and killed
by a police officer that officer and the
brooklyn center police chief
now stepping down my son was laying
there
unresponsive wright's connection to the
george floyd family
his girlfriend was a teacher for my
nephew and our derrick chovin trial
coverage continues as the defense
presents
its case chauvin's defense showing the
jury
body cam video from george floyd's past
arrest
plus the woman seen in the car with
george floyd on the day he died is
called to the stand by the defense
he said he was alert yes friendly yes
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome to law on crime daily i'm
angelica spanos in for brian buckmeyer
who's in minneapolis
covering the derek chauvin trial and
with us as always
is terry austin the defense is calling
its witnesses now
in the trial but before we get to that
brian buckmeyer is in front of the
courthouse
with how the prosecution wrapped up its
case brian
angelica day 12 saw the prosecution
resting in front of the jury
now prosecutors called 38 witnesses over
11 days
many of those were police officers
including the minneapolis police chief
two spark of life witnesses were called
to humanize george floyd
including his girlfriend courtney ross
and brother filonas floyd
the state also called top medical
experts eyewitnesses
and first responders in an attempt to
show that floyd died because of
chauvin's press knee
into george floyd's neck for nine
minutes and 29 seconds
chauvin is facing three charges of
second degree murder second degree
manslaughter and third degree murder
now prosecutors could still call
witnesses or experts after the defense's
case
if they choose to put on a rebuttal
all right thanks brian the defense began
their case with introducing into
evidence
george floyd's 2019 arrest by calling
the minneapolis police officer who
pulled him over
i approached the vehicle on the
passenger side
the pass-through window was down
i started giving the individual uh that
was on that was in the passenger seat
commands
several times the passenger was
unresponsive
and non-compliant to my commands i then
had to
physically reach in to because i wanted
to
see his hands because i couldn't see his
hands i reached in
finally and grabbed his hand to put it
up on the dash and then
that individual was taken from the
vehicle and handcuffed
did you observe the passenger put
anything in his mouth no i didn't
officer crane you were describing that
you
got mr floyd out of the car correct yes
and he stood next to the car and you
handcuffed him correct
me and another officer had to physically
handcuff him yes and he didn't fall down
correct no he didn't fall down
the defense next called to the stand the
paramedic who treated george floyd
after his arrest in 2019.
you able to learn that mr floyd had
consumed some narcotics
yes what did he tell you specifically
about what narcotics he had taken
and when he had taken
he he told me that he had
been taking multiple like every 20
minutes
um and it was a
i don't remember it was oxy or percocet
but it was a um opioid
based it wasn't real consistent with his
behavior
at that point was real elevated and
agitated so he told you that he
had been taking those pills throughout
the day right
yes and he i asked him why he said he's
because he was addicted
he told you he was addicted and he
responded to your questions about taking
the pills correct
correct and he was able to walk
correct yes he was able to stand up
correct and the defense recalled
a minneapolis police training officer
first called by the state
in order to show the jury the training
officer thomas lane received at the
police academy
in excited delirium
it's fair to say that once a person is
in handcuffs
under the excited delirium you train
officers to
put that suspect in the recovery
position agreed
correct and what would be the purpose of
um bringing ems on scene uh because
people that are
experiencing the excited delirium
syndrome uh
they can rapidly go into cardiac arrest
and that's how you train uh minneapolis
police cadets correct
correct now again as far as veteran
officers
they may not see this particular
training materials correct
they would not one of the things that
they are told to do
is to put the person in the side
recovery position correct that is
correct
and that's to help facilitate breathing
yes
because excited delirium if it exists
could compromise proper breathing it
absolutely yes
and officers both in the academy
and veteran officers are trained on cpr
yes and so um
they are also trained that they have an
obligation
if someone becomes pulseless
or unresponsive to initiate
measures such as cpr yes sir
all right time for some discussion now
coming to you first terry
why do you think the defense wanted to
recall
officer mckenzie to discuss that excited
delirium
well what nelson was trying to do here
was to use
the officer to show that stimulants like
methamphetamine could cause excited
delirium and
that could result in this excessive
strength that he's been talking about
all along and so she went through
what the signs were that someone might
be incoherent that they might be
resisting and of course nelson has been
trying to say
that that's exactly what george floyd
was doing but you heard there
on the cross by prosecution they
absolutely established the fact
that even if all of this was going on
you need to put someone in
a recovery position once they have been
handcuffed
and if that person is not responsive and
has signs that they
are you know dying essentially then you
need to
perform cpr so all in all i think this
witness actually was good for the
prosecution all right terry thanks and
brian with the fact that in 2019
obviously george floyd did not die
how can both the prosecution and the
defense use that
fact to their advantage do you think
so the offense is going to use this as a
show that this
is george floyd's mo that he pops pills
and he's about to get arrested but
for the prosecution i think it's even
stronger because both in the 2019 and
2020 arrests
george floyd did exactly the same thing
but in 2019 he survived
2020 he didn't what's the major
difference george george floyd
uh had a knee pressed into his neck for
over
nine minutes nine minutes and 29 seconds
to be exact so i think they're going to
definitely harp on that issue
all right brian terry thank you both
still ahead on law and crime daily a
police chief and police officer
stepping down after the fatal shooting
of a 20 year old man
but first george floyd's ex-girlfriend
takes the stand
what does she say about how he was
acting in the car with her
the day he died
[Music]
welcome back george floyd's
ex-girlfriend takes the stand to testify
about his demeanor the night he died
and a sudden change in his behavior law
on crime's internet levy is here with
her testimony internet
angelica shawanda hill was just one of
the people
in that suv with george floyd on the
night he died she was
also with him in the last hour or so
before police approached
i just got my phone fixed shawanda hill
was in the suv with maurice hall and
george floyd that fateful night last may
hill said she ran into floyd inside cup
foods
he offered to give her a ride how would
you describe
mr floyd's behavior while inside of the
cup foods
happy normal talking hill said they
spoke for about eight minutes when they
got into the suv
then she noticed a change in floyd who
was her ex-boyfriend
hill said floyd fell asleep before
employees from cup foods approached the
suv
about the counterfeit 20 bill when they
came there tried to wake him up
they tried to wake him up try to wake
him up over and over
and his friend tried to wake him up and
he kept he woke up
then he'll say something you know he
made a little gesture
you know and nodded back off hill can be
seen on body camera video from a couple
of the officers
including park police officer peter
chang did you guys take out the car
cigarettes you got your personal items
this is mine i had in my hand it was my
phone
hill could also see a little bit of what
was happening with police
and george floyd at the squad car yeah
he still won't get in the car
[Music]
on cross-examination prosecutors
questioned hill
about her perception of floyd's health
that day did he
complain of shortness of breath at all
no
did he complain of chest pains at all no
and did he seem
startled when the officer
pulled a gun
phil was actually kept at the scene as
you could see by that park police
officer that night
and she was actually pretty shocked once
she saw an ambulance arrived she said
later in that video that the police must
have done something to george floyd
eric nelson obviously wanted her to
testify because
he believes her testimony supports his
theory of what happened that night
that george floyd may have been
overdosing on drugs
angelica all right internet thanks brian
out to you with more on shawanda hill
here she had made a striking comment
that was objected
to but the jury heard it anyways so tell
us about that comment and elaborate how
that could affect the jury
yeah so lawyers call it as you can't
unring that bell yes of course
judge cahill is going to say you have to
ignore that it's not on the record
but when miss hill was testifying she
said that
uh yeah george floyd was falling asleep
but earlier on
in the store he said that he had worked
long hours now that was objected to
i think properly so but the jury now
heard it they're not going to unhear it
and now that's going to combat what eric
nelson is trying to argue that it was
the drugs that called him
caused him to slow down and fall asleep
they obviously heard that he also worked
long hours so the question becomes was
this witness really worth getting in
that small piece of information
when there was so much the prosecution
was able to use against him
right that's a good question there all
right terry the defense subpoena
shawanda hill we know that do you think
that her testimony was effective
absolutely not angelica i think it was
clear she didn't want to be there she
was impatient and at some point she was
dismissive
and i think that she actually confirmed
like brian said
issues for both sides on the one hand
she confirmed
yes floyd was sleepy he was incoherent
he was unresponsive
but then we saw on cross-examination by
the prosecution
that she also said he was startled when
he saw the gun
that he answered commands and he
responded so
i don't think that all in all it was a
good witness to call for the defense
and i think she basically came out even
for both sides
all right internet maurice hall was also
in the suv that night
do you think he's going to testify
yeah that's a very good question i think
we're all wondering about maurice hall
you could see him in that body camera
video with shawanda hill he was also in
the vehicle that night
there was some discussion today about
they were going into chambers eric
nelson
attorneys for the state and judge cahill
to discuss the availability of a witness
we believe that witness was maurice hall
so far we have not heard from him but we
know that the prosecution is not
offering him any type of immunity
in exchange for his testimony so we very
well may not see him he's already
indicated that he would invoke his fifth
amendment privilege against
self-incrimination
should he be called to testify okay
we'll be watching that
coming up on lawn crime daily when the
trial of a millionaire real estate heir
accused of murdering his best friend
will resume
plus hear from the mother of a man shot
and killed by a police officer
just miles away from the derek chopin
trial a family calls for justice
that's up next
[Music]
just miles down the road from the derek
shoving trial people are
taking to the streets after the fatal
shooting of an unarmed man
police now saying the officer
accidentally pulled out her gun
instead of her taser law and crime's kim
johnson is in minneapolis and explains
how the dante wright and george floyd
cases
have a connection kim
angelica family members of george floyd
have been showing up here
every day in the trial of the former
police officer accused of
killing him but on this day they showed
up for a different
purpose to provide comfort for another
grieving family
who's lost their loved one at the hands
of police
now the floyd family joined dante
wright's
family in a press conference outside the
hennepin county courthouse
wright was shot and killed by police
during the traffic stop on sunday
his mom described the last time she
talked to
and saw her son dante
put the phone down i heard some
scruffling he got out of the car and i
could hear the police officers
um and scruffling with him then they
heard the police officer asked them to
hang up the phone
they hung up the phone three or four
seconds went by i tried calling it back
to back to back
because i didn't know what was going on
and i never imagined this is what was
gonna happen i just thought maybe he was
being arrested
and then when i called back the girl
that he had in the car
answered the phone and it was on a
facetime
and she said she was crying and
screaming and she said that they shot
him
and she pointed the phone towards the
driver's seat and my son was laying
there
unresponsive that was the last time that
i seen my son
that's the last time i heard from my son
and i have had no explanation since then
brooklyn center police officer kim
potter allegedly thought that she was
using her
taser and not a handgun when she shot
right
she has resigned along with the city's
police chief
the state's bureau of criminal
apprehension is handling
the investigation now civil rights
attorney ben crump
is in minneapolis and is representing
the wright family he
said that he never thought less than a
year after
george floyd died at the hands of police
he would be
here again representing another family
and calling for justice for another
black man who died
in police custody angelica all right kim
and one of the witnesses that the state
called in derek shovin's trial
also has a connection to dante wright
tell us about that yeah you may remember
courtney ross she was george floyd's
girlfriend who gave very emotional
testimony about
who george floyd was as a person well
she was here during that press
conference
consoling dante wright's mother
apparently she had taught dante wright
at in high school at edison high school
she came
up to his mom katie wright and said
you know every day i saw dante in class
he always had a smile on his face very
emotional
interaction between those two and really
what a small world it is that these
two cases collide in this manner
absolutely kim thanks another story
we'll be following there
when we come back though we'll go back
into the courtroom for the derrick
chauvin trial
our exclusive legal analysis that you
don't want to miss
is coming up
welcome back the trial of a millionaire
real estate heir accused of murdering
his best friend in california will
resume
next month we're talking about robert
durst and his murder trial was put on
pause last march due to the covet 19
pandemic
a judge has denied the defense's motion
for a mistrial
due to the quote extreme delay durst is
accused of murdering susan berman at her
home near los angeles
prosecutors say durst killed berman
because she was a
witness in the still unsolved
disappearance of his first wife cassie
the trial is scheduled to resume on may
17. jurors will be called in for
questioning and then
a new round of opening statements will
be delivered back
now to the derek chauvin trial where
prosecutors have rested their case but
before they did
they called one final witness an expert
in use of force both
the knee across mr floyd's neck
and the prone restraint were
unreasonable
excessive and contrary to generally
accepted police practices
when in your opinion did the
unreasonable force begin
when mr floyd was initially put into the
prone restraint position and when the
defendant's knee
uh was placed onto his neck and when did
it end
when the defendant's knee was lifted off
of mr floyd and he was taken out of the
prone restraint position
you observe do you observe him continue
to
uh kick his back legs
are you talking about as he as he is
brought down to the ground
yep initially so there's one movement
that's captured on i believe
officer kings and officer tao's body
cameras
that looks to me as if officer lane is
grabbing mr floyd's leg
and pulling it and straightening it and
rotating it that is my interpretation of
what is happening there
so yeah he was definitely controlling
his life
meantime as the derrick chauvin defense
presents its case our chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
spoke with a high-profile defense
attorney who has some words of advice
for their team
this week on brian ross investigates the
case for
derek schuffen we'll talk with a top
criminal lawyer who has defended
a number of police officers and never
lost a case
here's his strategy for defending derek
shovin
you know i hate the second guest lawyers
because these type of cases really have
to get in your dna brian
but i was surprised to see that they
never made a comment at all about the
video
on opening the defense attorney asked
the
doctor the cardiologist are you saying
that
if mr floyd got into the back of the car
that he would not be dead today and he
said he looked at him and said yeah
and i scratched my head and i said why
did he ask that question
that's the whole point the prosecution's
trying to make
that's this week on brian ross
investigates on the law and crime
trial network
and for our final discussion here brian
what witness do you think is going to
offer the most for the defense
the defense has to put on a medical
expert to say that
it could have been the drugs it could
have been his heart failures and it
wasn't in fact the knee
of derrick shoved on george floyd's neck
that killed him so anything that makes
sense right now
and terry we've seen a number of
witnesses for the defense so far how do
you think that they're doing
well i think nelson is doing the best he
can under these circumstances but i
think the witnesses
are basically doing as much for the
defense as they are for the prosecution
i mean when you look at the expert that
he brought
in just talking about force i think the
jury is going to decide
that the force was not reasonable all
right thank you for joining us here on
law on crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss
justice in america thanks for joining us
[Music]
you